this is probably illegal but once again  I think it's my duty to share these  calls between mr. Trump and President  Obama with you right now let's go hello  there what are the new codes well it's a  very complicated series of protocols I'm  gonna make it seven that's it just seven  that way I can remember it Iran access  that is it dad Jackie Chan as the  Secretary of self-defense already does  what a good one that's incredibly  condescending and racist to tell a black  person they're one of the good ones  black person so I met Muslim Melania you  want to sleep in my room today Donald  this is Barack Obama I think you dialed  the wrong number  oh sorry Brett you want to sleep in my  room tonight hello Iraq stay on the line  what are you doing I'm calling kim  jeong-hoon  at conferencing you in oh that's a bad  idea  come on I'm gonna do a funny Asian boy  [Applause]  you